congratulations on your special stage
fright it's really funny and one of the
things that I love you talk about is you
talk about there's some comics that
we'll talk about say their parents or
their grandparents you talk about your
your grandma your grandmother's yeah
plural and then you put them in the
special that's right yeah that's that's
a little gutsy you know maybe you would
both relate to the fact that like if
you're a person and you want to be funny
or you're comedian everyone's like
you're exaggerating you're just
exaggerating and for my grandmother's
I'm like no no no they are like this
kooky this real and I'm just doing like
a tan impression of them they don't
nothing needs to happen they just need
to show up right my Nana Kanye talked
about her in the specialist that hurt
voice sounds like diamonds being rolled
around in the dust and her heads like
Nancy Reagan and her body's like a
shrimp with Eagle talons very good
police description yeah totally Reagan
head body of a shrimp Eagle Talon sky
she came in here she thinkin grats on
your bat mitzvah then she left yeah but
and then my other Nana has a crazy
accent because she grew up speaking like
a many many different languages and now
she just sounds like kind of like a baby
and she just eats like mustard and salty
fishes but you you you go you're nice
because it feels like you have a good
you know relationship with them do you
visit your grandmother she was going
yeah though I do oh yeah that's a big
thing with them as oh my grandkids I
don't visit enough that's how they
always feel do you visit uh yeah I feel
like I call my Nana Connie and I'm like
hi nan she's like okay good to talk to
you like like hangs up immediately but
my uh she's fine but my other Nana lives
in like an elderly Jewish person's
community and I went to visit her
recently and she's just at that point of
life where she's like does not care
anymore like she's just gonna do what
she wants to do right I would think at a
certain point you feel like I'm just
gonna go for it yeah yeah she's like
[ __ ] like she's just doing her thing and
so I went to visit her
and we were I said you know Nana I got
engaged which was like I wanted to tell
her that mostly because when we were
filming the special she was like we
gonna be alone to ever like you me she
would tell you pretty much you're going
to be alone yeah I'm not going to marry
and she and you and her will always be
alone together yeah together in a in a
which boy I know makes it even worse the
witch voice makes everything work but so
I we were I told her we got engaged and
that we walked through the library in
her old persons community and there was
like just happened to be in the Metro
section of the Boston Globe a picture of
me and my fiance saying that we got
engaged have you got a shout-out in the
globe shout out in the globe yeah yeah I
know about these I'm from I'm from
Austin and that's the thing that always
makes my parents happy is if I go home
to Boston and there's like you know
scene-stealing women's underwear Conan
O'Brien you know they don't care they're
like you got mentioned in the globe yeah
that's right it's it's just the globe
yeah it's like you mean like Marky Mark
that's it that's right he stole
underwear with me wants you guys you
guys um anyway we I like oh man like
here we are
and she's like taped it and I was like
what and then I looked around and there
were all of these like handwritten
printed out signs that say like the
person who steals people like pieces
from the paper doesn't respect this
community like you are rude if you say
this is a common room newspaper that's
supposed to stay in that room yeah and I
was like man I can't take this for you
they say like there's all these signs
and she was like take it I really don't
want to like I don't want to steal this
from the library and like of it like an
elderly Jewish person's home it's just
not right right and she just like
bullied me into stealing the newspaper
and I and I like where I rolled it up
and I was like truly like put it down my
sweater I was like I'm just gonna get in
so much trouble and yeah like man we
can't take it and she was like just like
a general
what have they taken from her they've
sheltered her and fed her yeah really